journalist and moderator Kate Boozer is
searching for answers for months she's
been asking Germans about their language
and their eating habits and this is the
result meet the Germans a new series of
web videos on DWS website and YouTube
channel
starting today I'm Kate and today on
meet the Germans I'm gonna share with
you five of my favorite hilarious German
idioms first up dust is near Vorst
literally it's sausage to me now
everyone knows Germans love sausage but
this idiom doesn't exactly do justice to
their favorite food so what does it mean
I asked a few German learners to take
their best guess this is me I am father
Felix is concerned - nicht mir that is
good for me
actually the sesame awashed has nothing
to do with sausage but let's find out
from a sausage seller if he can tell us
what the idiom really means this is my
Gliscor dish does make lies that doesn't
mean that Germans don't care about
sausage though it's still one of the
most popular foods here the daughter
Natasha Susie savor Germans tend to
underestimate themselves I've
experienced that a lot they forget to
laugh at themselves once in a while
and they forget they have a very rich
culture that deserves to be celebrated
and treasured and I wanted to convey
that not only to Germans but to non
Germans as well Mazhar was born in
California but has lived in Germany for
13 years she's been with Deutsche Welle
since 2006 working as culture journalist
for its English service as well as
hosting TV shows she's also active on
social media whether on Twitter or
YouTube and she's putting all of her
experience to good use on the project
meet the Germans
we won't up and boys probably come up we
want to reach a new audience
sure DW programs already attract a large
audience but I think we can reach a new
one through YouTube some episodes are
produced entirely in the studio users
experience as a foreigner living in
Germany are an integral part of the show
how do you know when to say do & Windus
AZ that's especially difficult for
English speakers in Germany since we
just have one word for you in English
and honestly it took me a couple of
years and quite a few faux pas to get it
down the web series comprises 12
episodes to start and the German
language plays a major role cake Muser
aims to find out what terms of
endearment Germans use for their loved
ones or the toughest German tongue
twisters on the sleep flight out of
darknesses water fears or shield is also
special consumed in a battle - there's a
central hold stricter human demolition
is in Vegas a lot soonest or just watch
it Easter Canada tejas and so Swedish as
it is a session for me it's as important
as any java kebun
and it's also a practical advantage that
Kate Boozer brings to the project a
fresh but affectionate approach to
German culture the logical Taurus
Waterman culture is wonderfully diverse
you don't have to be born in Germany to
identify with the culture and I hope for
Germans too that this open approach to
identity will continue to develop often
Ommegang myths with a identity
production of the next episodes of meet
the Germans has already begun so stay
tuned to learn some funny German names
for animals and cakes and to find out
what you should avoid doing at all costs
in Germany
[Music]